i am curious though about the bob
burgers
bob's burgers movie um what's the status
of that
it's coming working working uh
hard on it uh excited to bring it out
into the world excited also to bring it
out at the right time
uh we're not you know we do not want to
be the first movie back in theaters
at all i mean i know we're not already
we're not the first but we don't we're
not in a hurry to be
in in theaters until it's really
uh come back uh people are going to the
movies and feel
safe and you know comfortable there um
and we have to finish it
so we're you know it's not um
you know it's not next month uh we don't
have a date yet we'll announce very soon
um but we are we're hard at work on it
up late at night i don't know if you can
tell
um but uh hard at work
uh will will it resolve where uh this
the show takes place
oh the nameless seaside town is that
what you mean we've actually said it
in the episode it's just been it just
went by quickly
it was a blink and you miss it i'm not
going to say it now because now it feels
like a thing